is there some
advice you can give on how to best study
mathematics so what's the role of the
student outside the classroom
yeah i think one thing we know is a lot
of people when they review material
whether it's maths or anything else
don't do it in the best way
i think a problem a lot of people have
is they read through maybe a teacher's
explanation or a way of doing maths
and it makes sense and they think oh
yeah i've got that and they move on
um but then it's not until you come to
try and work on something and do a
problem that you actually realize you
didn't really understand it just seemed
to make sense
so i would say
this is also something that
neuroscientists talk about
to keep giving yourself questions is a
really good way to
study
rather than looking through lots of
material
it's almost like giving yourself lots of
tests
is a good way to actually deeply
understand things and know what you do
when you don't understand so would the
questions be
in the form of
the material you're reviewing is the
answer to that question or is it almost
like beyond it's the polygon thing you
mentioned from a square is it almost
like i wonder
what is the bigger picture i was kind of
asking
like how's this extended and so on yeah
that that would be great and it's a
similar i mean a question i get asked a
lot is about homework what this is a
good thing for kids to do for homework
and one of the recommendations i give is
to
not have kids just do lots of questions
for homework
but to actually ask them to reflect on
what they've learned like what was the
big idea you were you learned today or
what did you
find difficult what did you struggle
with what was something that was
exciting
then kids go home and they have to kind
of reflect in a deeper way a lot of
times i don't know if you have this
experience as a math student lots of
people do
kids are going through maths questions
they're successful they get them right
but they don't even really know what
they're about
they and a lot of kids go through many
years of maths like that doing lots of
questions but that really knowing what
even
the topic is or what it's about what
it's important for so
having students go back and think at the
end of a day what was the big idea
from this maths lesson why is it
important
where would i find that in real life
those are really good questions for kids
to be thinking about it's probably for
everybody to be thinking about i think
most of us go through life never asking
like the bigger question almost like
you know those like layers of why
questions that kids ask when they're
very young yeah we need to keep doing
that
we do like what uh that's the you know
whatever the term is you call first
principles thinking some people call it
that
which is like
why
are we doing it this way
so one one nice thing
is to do that because there's usually a
good answer like the reason we did it
this way
is because it works for this reason
but then if you want to do something
totally novel is you'll say well
we've been doing it this way
because of historical reasons but really
this is not the best way to do it there
might be other ways
and that's how invention happens right
and then you get you know that's really
useful in every aspect of life like
choosing your career
choosing your um
i don't know what where you live yeah
who you're like romantic partner is like
everything everything yeah and i think
it probably starts
doing that in math class
that would be good if we started doing i
want i mean i wonder
i
i probably didn't do very much of that
for most of my education
asking why except for later much later
in the subjects on like grad school when
you're doing research on them
when your first task of doing something
novel
using this
or solving a problem really outside the
classroom and have to publish on it is
the first time you think
wait why are these things
interesting useful which are the things
that are useful
and yeah i guess that was that would be
nice if we did that much earlier that
the quest of invention yeah yeah
you